des questions on vous trouve l'info yvan
de montréal a commandé un ordinateur
portable de 3500 $
postes canada a laissé le colis sur son
perron et quelqu'un a volé depuis le
début de la pandémie postes canada a
instauré la politique
sonnez déposé quitter sauf exception
elle n'exige plus de signatures même si
le commerçant la demande est ce qui peut
compliquer un remboursement ou une
rétrofacturation alors quoi faire si
vous ne recevez pas votre colis en
colombie-britannique et au québec
si le contrat a été conclu à distance le
commerçant a l'obligation de prendre les
moyens pour que vous receviez votre
commande
l'office de la protection du
consommateur précise adressez vous aux
commerçants et aux besoins exercez-vous
recours contre lui et non contre
l'entreprise de livraison et le fait que
le livreur et pris une photo du paquet à
votre porte ne prouve rien ivan a dû se
battre pendant un mois
finalement le commerçant la rembourser
rappelez-vous au québec et en
colombie-britannique
c'est le commerçant qui est responsable
pour les ontariens
la loi est muette sur cette
responsabilité
ça ne vous empêche pas de demander le
remboursement ou une rétrofacturation
vous aussi mais vous devrez vérifier qui
a cette responsabilité dans votre
contrat passé le mot
[Musique]